alexis poplin bonjour merci d'être avec
nous ce matin alors emmanuel macron se
veut moteur de la coop 26 pourtant à
l'intérieur de nos frontières le chef de
l'état n'a pas tenu ses promesses
formulées au début de son mandat au
contraire son bilan est critiquée par
les défenseurs de l'environnement
oui la loi climat bien en deçà de ce qui
avait été promis on se rappelle
évidemment de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat avec beaucoup d'idées
posé sur la table et puis toutes mises
de côté par emmanuel macron il y a
toujours chez lui ce en même temps avec
un énorme décalage entre les paroles et
les actes de mecs planète great game où
il essaye d'avoir cette posture
internationale de sauveur du climat à la
réalité en france où toutes les
politiques depuis qu'il est au pouvoir
et son gouvernement sont en deçà de ce
qui avait été promis donc on peut se
demander que cherche emmanuel macron si
ce n'est encore une fois se mettre en
scène de la communication et n'oublions
pas qu'il est en campagne même sans le
dire du g20 à la coop 26 est pour lui
une façon en or d'essayer de se
positionner à nouveau en champion de
pima ce qu'il n'est pas loin de là en
france et justement nous sommes à
quelques mois de cette élection
présidentielle quel enjeu politique
revêt cette co 26 pour emmanuel macron
bien plusieurs d'abord c'est une coop de
rendez-vous 2015 et 2021 c'est voir où
en sont les engagements de paris la
france avait un rôle moteur en 2015 at
elle toujours un rôle moteur aujourd'hui
ça reste à voir et l'idée c'est bien sûr
pour lui de se poser en champion du
climat international comme je le disais
il continue bien sûr sur cette
communication même si personne n'est
dupe au moins en france et un peu en
europe il est pour lui important de
continuer à dire qu'il sera un des
champions on voit bien france 2030
l'écologie n'est pas au rendez vous bien
sûr toutes les ambitions ont été revues
à la baisse on voit que d'un côté il
lutte contre la déforestation
mais en france on a des pénuries de bois
la filière bois est très inquiète donc
il ya vraiment un risque en fait oublier
le pays à oublier en fait comment dans
ce global it est un que veut embrasser
mon imac rond il peut être un président
actif est vraiment avoir un bilan à
défendre sur l'écologie en l'occurrence
son bilan m mais mais la communication
suffit pour lui et c'est encore un
exercice de communication d'ailleurs
toutes les coptes ont été
malheureusement puisqu'elles sont
rarement suivies d'effet c'est vraiment
pour mettre en scène ses leaders
internationaux qui décide de parler et
des paroles aux actes comme je le disais
hé bien c'est jamais vraiment une
incarnation ou bien au contraire est ce
que finalement aujourd'hui la protection
de l'environnement est une des
principales préoccupations des français
c'est un discours qui revient beaucoup
aujourd'hui un thème en tout cas que
l'on entend sur plusieurs plateaux de
candidats qui sont déclarés à la
présidentielle oui alors c'est un
passage obligé à maintenant tout le
monde doit avoir un discours sur
l'écologie sur le réchauffement
climatique sur comment contrer ses
problèmes il ya aussi un vrai problème
de société on parle des coq cité pour
les jeunes générations qui ne se
projette pas dans l'avenir qu'ils ont
l'impression que le mur climatique
arrive et que aujourd'hui les dirigeants
d'aujourd'hui sont incapables ou bien en
deçà de ce qu'on leur demande donc oui
tout tous les politiques maintenant ont
un discours sur le réchauffement
climatique et l'écologie du localisme
jusqu'à l'utilisation du nucléaire pour
produire de l'énergie mais la réflexion
globale sur celle du monde d'après sur
celle de la façon de produire tout en
consommant moins est-ce qu'il faut pas
justement voir les moyens de production
la chine typiquement à qui explose tous
les bilans carbone possibles et
imaginables
elle continue parce que on a avec la
mondialisation demandé à la chine de
produire pour la planète donc on peut
pas continuer en réalité avec des
discours d'un côté et puis
l'organisation mondiale du commerce qui
pousse encore pour une globalisation et
de mondialisation des échanges alors
qu'on sait quel est leur impact sur le
climat ça suffit aussi je crois de
rendre anxieux les jeunes de les rendre
aussi responsable puisque à chaque fois
on demande à chaque individu de faire
beaucoup pour la planète mais très peu
au niveau des organisations
internationales ou de l'organisation du
commerce mondial merci beaucoup à
l'excès poulain d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
éditorialiste politique